what are you doing it  alright it's about your mom why are you  here to drop off the apology check yeah  yeah this is the point when my mother  usually throws money at the problem  I miss grant didn't send me I came  because I have never seen your mother  like this before like one scared I'm not  getting enough retweets no no losing you  like hey she did just fine for 25 years  or she was really good at pretending I  know you think your mom is this  heartless narcissistic monster her words  some days I do too but when you get past  that there is this inspiring person in  there a hero you talk about it like  she's Supergirl well  in some ways she is and sometimes being  a hero means making sacrifices  deep down she always knew there was  something big she needed to do and if  she could go back and do it all over  again I don't think she'd change a  single thing except leaving you  you